yeah welcome to this video playing BB DD
and goodnight to do let's play this
knight c6 line again the gig not to hope
what what what was the line on this
rules we should be 70 f 6 mm ok let's
play of six if yeah I really forgot it
probably i'm getting dismantled badly if
you forget the theory on move 6 or ok
forgetting us maybe too much if you
never have known the theory then move
six you probably have have a problem
this looks very shaky yeah
okay hmm but this is too is this so bad
I take here and then c6 and take only
five just too too much a bond is a bond
check did I have to didn't then dive
this recently in a game where the where
no Bishop ich7 was played don't really
know but this this shouldn't be too too
awful why does the Queen goal it doesn't
have a really great square
yeah this looks like an opening gone
wrong no the Queen has no square can go
to g4 but this runs yeah this runs right
into with this is e five min with Andy
form now can try to to make a sacrifice
out of it but I doubt that it's really a
really working especially this night on
f7 is a great piece it covers all kinds
of all sensitive squares h6 g5 it's a
great defense of peace I know I am just
a piece up for just for absolutely
nothing for porn okay Bishop f5 a serm
is coming
yeah it's just trying to find some way
to just to do to stir up some trouble
it's uh it's basically just a just a
piece take here they take e to air tech
a tune the rocker doesn't really have a
great square of course I don't mind for
the exchanges it's a piece so maybe grab
this one and then return yep let's just
return night back to f7 next and this
should cover up nicely okay well this is
Sun okay but it's not not threatening
it's nothing threatened at the moment is
what I'm trying to say
95 maybe 95 assess threat
okay i want to activate PCM
I'm trying to exchange something 92mm
yahoo 92 I saw that but I thought okay
just take a stroll but it's not clear
that this actually helps weight but this
this should help Queenie five i get i
get i have 25 okay but here and Queen f4
possibly
I come on him
oh wait maybe g4 that's an idea
hmm yo not actually winning the prize
for best technical player him
not sure that g4 was good though I
thought this one and then queen d 5 I
hope this is strong here
and Knight to e5 J
what the heck Queen somewhere it's not
it's really really great Jim
97 checker would tonight be six check
can you believe that ah what the heck I
was just a piece of I'm such an idiot
yeah I have section in it Wow losing
this is really heartbreaking I mean just
a piece up ah yeah everything winds
really everything but the shouldn't I
shouldn't have allowed this in the first
place I mean this is just completely
idiotic allowing any kind of entry here
just night f7 and its debt completely
dead I mean okay it will give it to a
combat laughs at you it's just plus four
but it's it gets shaky it's got this is
this pesky night and so on and yeah this
is yes it's still a complete win but now
we need to be precise probably King g8
as in facts to the draw yeah I thought
it's lost here anyway to be honest King
f6 here and still winning
yeah it was very hard not to win the
game really hard today I managed yeah
well thanks for watching